see what it was
okay so we know on showmanuchi
right
uh he's going to one not start
out there he starts out there
go I'm gonna move
it doesn't make sense
strikes are closer to range strives are
closer to the range than katate because
his Target is closer than Kentucky you
see he's in range okay
and then we know on some energy that I
address it as it's going up
I never address it on its way down I
don't care what deflection angle you're
doing
you catch it on its way up
right
okay
so on almost go I step with the lead
foot
we're gonna need
I step with the back foot you gotta not
uh worry about me you got to keep your
attack going okay
there he goes I stepped with the outside
foot now he pressure whoa too much still
too much
here he goes too much
and when I feel that you might move out
of the way
same orientation
okay so catch it and you don't do that
just you're gonna you want to hit me
okay
he goes oh too much you hear that little
slap
so I made contact
there who's spot two do you hear it no
it's it's yield
[Music]
and in that sense it's still different
than this one that I was eating kept in
a Yin phase
too much
okay what's key is that okay actually
throws the strike is not posting at the
top not having her hand up
okay
all right it's it looks much easier but
I'll show you where there's some
differences okay so on the first one my
hand should be the same I'm not going to
be on the outside
because that Hound's gonna hit
and I want the hand I don't want to
deflect it okay if you wanted to deflect
it sure Let It Go by
and in this technique I the elbow is
what I'm going for so the elbow I kept
here
boom okay now when he comes down I don't
want to grab his arm
that arm's coming that arm that elbows
that wrist is flying you're not going to
catch it from going behind it
and I don't need to
the warm I'll just on the elbow just on
the elbow
you see and it's here is where if you
wanted to
you can catch his face
if you wanted to okay so boom pay
attention
again you can move around
I don't need that
I don't need his
arm my arms are gonna continue to roll
his elbow
to the up position
his elbows down
so there's no way you can stay here do
you see
but as you come around
his arms coming down
you keep rolling it at the elbow
[Music]
foreign
my task is this
boom
boom okay and I want to show you the the
hard Parts okay
foreign
I'm not going fast
let's let it buy her again okay
there's that jam
did you feel that
same thing
[Music]
oh I Jam again
so your Technique
this is on the side you think and she's
trying to pull it
so you're trying to pull it so hold it
right who has the all right
energy
okay
so
again if I'm on the side it's gonna go
by me
there's no way
and if I go
and connect on the top
I had to go on the side and it's gonna
keep going
right he didn't finish his step
and now we're moving away from each
other
so I have to come off
and then this becomes the axis of
rotation
he comes down
[Music]
never on the side though
he's I'm just yielding whoa
you get it slow you pause it at the top
easy peasy
right but God striking
not easy
with that easy